what we're doing in Ukraine is not good
for the Ukrainian people we have killed
300 000 Ukrainian troops 14 000
civilians we have not killed any
Ukrainian troops we have not killed any
Ukrainian troops I'm trying to think
what on Earth is he talking about what
could he mean we've killed 300 000
Ukrainian troops Russia has maybe I
don't know if that's even the number
Russia has killed Ukrainian troops but
only if you interpret this to mean
that we the U.S
caused induced or forced Russia to
invade Ukraine could you say we have
anything to do with the killing of
Ukrainian troops so this is really
Bonker stuff just the Chaos Agent per
Steve Bannon right the user Steve Bannon
term this is a Chaos Agent